so I'm playing chess let's play let's
play c4
let's fight English have a lot of
London's lately I try and mix it up a
little bit
g6 so blacks gonna play Kings Indian
[Music]
I'll play mainline I had a game the
other day which went down this path it
starts out as mainline yeah this is all
and played thousands tens of thousands
of times before and now g4 let's move
sometimes gets people to think house a
positional trap to it I played this once
or twice on stream already within the
past week
I should really do some more research in
this line okay f4 is considered dubious
the problem for black is now the
kingside just closes down there's no
effective breakthrough if H 5 then G 5 H
6 g 5 H 5 and meanwhile white has very
simple attacking ideas on the queenside
I've seen some people argue that this
physician is strategically winning for
whites I had this like two days ago I
think John Davis John Davis has been the
first in the chat at least a few times
this week congratulations lightning bolt
Bernie Sanders diaper
Daymond dance 23:06 Roy G and the
illusion marks Onaga jacuzzi CS Lucas
Matos 96 Magnum meais haw kites
oh yeah the go live notification said
bullet blitz rapid or classical question
mark so you guys can tell me what to do
John Davis I mean watching chest
streamers is not a bad life and our
schedule is lined up nice yeah I I
assume most people who watch at least at
this time are either night owls in the
US or there what do you call morning
people early morning people in Europe
and in Asia it's like normal like
afternoon probably writes about to be
afternoon depending on the region
watching a video of me playing arena
Kings nice a5 okay so my opponent took a
long think there I'm just gonna continue
with stuff I think the bishop belongs on
f2 control the nice diagonal support
this pawn I can be patient yeah I'll
just slowly build up no need to rush
even though I'm half Russian my active
on reddit
would you call people and reddit that
like consume but don't really comment
lurkers probably a lurker most of the
time Knight c5 do I want to trade
Knights not sure it wouldn't hurt I
guess I'll just leave the tension if
takes takes and it should be easier for
me to play eventually be for in c5
this Knight is actually very troubled
this is far away from accessing the
square it's in the way of the Queen and
it's really not an easy position for
black to come up with plans or ideas
like c8 welcome back so what are people
saying
Oh early bird is named so there's a
night owl and early bird but owls are
birds can you be an early bird and an
owl or maybe not
when am i visiting Brazil I'm visiting
Brazil in 2011 eight years ago I was
there once for the there's a world under
18 Championships
my only like international youth event
that I've ever played in it's only one I
qualified for and I only qualified for
it because I won the national high
school championship my junior year of
high school and leading up to like going
to Raziel I had studied Spanish for like
three years in high school and then I
was disappointed because I found out
like maybe a few months beforehand that
they don't speak Spanish in Brazil they
speak Portuguese but there's a nice
experience spent most of the time and
called us novus it's a small kind of
touristy town players came in from all
over the world it was pretty cool yeah I
guess I guess if the owl wakes up early
and then it is an early bird or early
owl how do you make red circles magic
red circle here oh wait that's a green
circle there we go yeah it's all about
magic or just holding down the shift-key
it's kind of a random move so there's a
typical idea very positional kind of
concept that light should not play a
three first if I play a three first a
four shuts me down the one pod would fix
two ponds so the usually the proper
approach is to play B 3 and then a 3 and
then later B 4 so let's start with B 3
it's little play but I mean I have time
slowly but surely
aha so the break but not really a break
I don't feel so broken and g5 deserves
the next clan at least one excellent
closing down the whole kingside so now
there's no no possible pawn breaks
except on the queenside now there is
Bishop h3 may be possible if this were a
bug house I would be scared because the
Queen on g2 would be mate so the Queen's
not getting - G - so I have a pawn the
left three so do I play a3 first also
does black have any sort of crazy
attacking ideas probably not I have 95
if I wants
okay I should just play a three before
incoming well hello to more people
extreme dota XXX ten touch s JK boarders
tape shaped clewd
Ram Gershon King h7 so box kind of
waiting for for his doom maybe Queen c2
first so I connect the rooks also
thinking king h2 could be useful move
it's like Queen c2 first yeah there's
really no rush in this position okay
long question Oh a short question first
when is a a3 rule the case wait what Oh
so as I was explaining earlier you
shouldn't play a3 a flock can shut you
down with with a four if there's a pawn
on b2 because it's a case where one fun
one pawn fixes two pawns unless a four
would be weak but that wasn't the case
when the bishop was on d7 it was
supported by three pieces and now the
point is with upon and B 3 a 4 is always
met with B 4 there's no autoscent so all
about of expanding patiently bits from
pistol McDonald wow first time in
Chicago oh man I've I mean Chicago the
city right not the suburbs because
honestly I I grew up in the suburbs so
my knowledge of like what to do downtown
isn't as extensive as other people who
live in Chicago who actually live in
Chicago
but if it's your first time I mean you
should go to go to Millennium Park see
the beam go to North Avenue beach if you
play chess go to the chest pavilion
North Avenue beach is great
I'm sure the weather is nice so Queen
eight stops the battery there stops some
it creates a battery and prevents me
from playing before but I have this move
wait Knight b5 might be five rook be
sevens force and then before once I draw
no drop I like my chances
now before so if take sticks I just take
over the a file I play c5 here maybe not
yet let's move back still being patient
at least trying to be okay so the
battery whoa it's a donation clear on
clear I'm donated Oakley Rhine
underscore donated 376 thanks for the
kind of random number donation in gold
uh story hello good to see you
I saw you streaming earlier also saw you
trying to get into Wow last night was
that successful I know there is a wait
also gold a story of people know this
but gold a story was in st. Louis a few
days ago and I got a goes mainly for her
but I've been eating the a goes but
eating that I goes with like frozen
mangoes it's so delicious with the maple
syrup just about out Rock v8 so block is
really trying to prepare for that a doom
I can't play c5 right away
well get in Knight b5 this rook should
be on more useful square it's very
common in chess when you're like about
to break through with your pawns usually
first you should optimize your pieces
especially if you have time and here I
pretty much have a lot of time in the
world so I should really try and find
the ideal squares for all the pieces now
maybe Knight b5 not sure if I should go
for an IP 5 or c5 or Bishop f1 cuz my
Feingold a Queen e2 well block wants to
do this maybe rook b1 rook b1 will
prepare c5 maybe actually rook b1 I'll
move the Queen away and then Martin I've
rook will be aligned nicely with box
Queen and the works defended very well
and b1 please put lots of butter on a go
it makes it taste better or does it make
a taste butter I she don't own I've
never bought butter or I have not bought
powder in the last like two or three
years never had the need trying to avoid
too much like saturated fat ok c5 takes
takes we could trade stuff
but I don't want to trade too much stuff
maybe Queen d2 first Queen d2
yeah just getting out of the way or the
modern phrases get out the way here it's
just preparing c5 so then if takes takes
and I hit this c6 will maybe come
probably still c5 honestly like this
whole plan well I've been doing was
pretty clear from the moment black
played out for it took a lot of time so
like play play B 3 and then a 3 and B 4
and finally get in c5 but things are
kind of culminating and this is still
probably not like completely easily
winning for whites but it's still very
pleasant and with the time situation
blocks under a lot of pressure there's a
lot of things to worry about like taking
either pawn alignment on C file now now
the linemen on the B file considering
something to be v c6 also playable
maybe rook rook somewhere allows working
one
I shouldn't take too much time here I
mean there's really no threat from black
should really just find a easy improving
move
maybe Queenie - lets play Queenie -
there's some slightly better placements
more support over b5 bettin Feingold did
visit but did not I didn't really get a
chance to even say hi to him like he he
arrived in town and he just disappeared
I was so sad okay do I play c6 now maybe
five
there should be five first even rugby -
maybe rugby - preparing some kind of
double up
you know time is gonna be a factor very
soon maybe Queen c2 back just maintain
the tension I think trading a pair of
rooks is is fine for me because now
there's there's no more battery
potential
I mean rookie three might be playing
okay three maybe rugby one to attack so
Bishop Yates like queen bee one here
have this nice battery directed towards
the king hard to actually use that
though mark III interesting
she probably defense I'm debating
whether to trade rooks
well night b5 loses f3 in the end 92
wait my knight wants to be on c4 okay
gonna play Queen c2 preparing Knight B 1
- D - 2 C 4 positions like this you have
to ask yourself the right questions can
i out pun been fine ville I don't think
that's a relevant question to ask in the
specific position Oh GM their jet ski
yeah I'll I would play some games yeah
send me a challenge can use the
challenge command last time I played in
there I did ski I almost adopted him but
not really I won the first two and then
he just started smashing me but it was a
good match okay so my Knights is
maneuvering at least beginning to
maneuver I'm gonna get out the pin so c4
is a promised land
whoa what does this Bishop a4 I mean
that's a move yeah that's a move Queen
c3 probably ass bishop d1 coming just
gonna attack me from behind
actually bishop d1 I have rook d2
hitting the rook and the bishop
well what does this move oh it's tactics
this is very nifty yeah this is gonna
get really crazy really quickly takes e4
Bishop d4 takes takes takes takes I
might just dead there takes ouch that's
not good yeah I probably should have
seen the danger there now I'm facing the
consequences steak steak okay oh can i I
have an idea
it might work might not work
okay what if I just play Queen d2 what's
the worse that happens I just lose a
pond maybe it's not so bad that moves
back I wanted to play a Queen d2 here
problem is just pawn takes Bishop okay
I'm worse here but it's gonna be a time
scramble Jay grease her with a sub wait
what I just take this ah he's gonna win
c5 huh and I have one ideas maybe Knight
c3 I was getting a little bit
uncomfortable and by a little bit I mean
very like I might actually lose this
take stick stick sticks oh I can take
first okay let's take on d6 first
there's no not f1 thank God cause Bishop
f1 no I I win the pawn back White's
probably actually I don't know how to
evaluate this I have the d5 square
bishop power first it feels like I'm
worse but this bishops garbage yeah I'm
not sure what's going on and this rook
is gonna be annoying for a while we're
both getting low on time so okay takes
takes takes e4 and then I can take with
Queen that's okay
b5 let's control the C file
hmm
you can't play Brooks e7f for looks bad
I mean what else to do
it's Queen d2 just defending over
defending there's a lot of tension with
this like d5 square
we're both running very low on time well
does this move the King to a better
place
Queen D for coming maybe 24 we trade
stuff oh he wants to play Queen g'wan a
rook G 1 so I have Queen III Queen trade
is okay I get some endgame this is rated
rapid it's gonna happen in season a flag
thought to flag whoa I was close okay
I'm gonna win b5 oh this should be
winning now takes takes takes and now do
i goes for the office of Clarke Bishop
ending I think that's just winning
because these pawns are fixed on light
squares so after Bishop takes d5 pawn
takes d5 I mean okay the bishops gonna
land here but then the problem for black
will be that my king will help the pawn
and this King runs over and then I win
these pawns I just have to worry about
bishops axe let's start with start with
King f2 and then
disappear
oh maybe I should have played this first
too late now
um let's move back okay this is not the
best time came technique trying to
figure out this variation if I walk my
King up the bishop comes in okay let's
put the pawn here first
I should my bishop be on e6 maybe it
should I wanna draw
I'm pretty sure this is winning but I'm
gonna be patient
take my time and maneuver the bishop
like this make the King decide where it
wants to go and then if I walk this way
this way takes here goes back yeah it
should be winning cuz my bishop ole will
stop the H pawn from advancing good
morning - Thomas 3/7 interesting - move
up
she would like to target this pond
I for it doesn't really accomplish much
okay going for this line ooh interesting
oh can I actually break through here
wait this is a new challenge can I not
break through that's kind of annoying
how do I break through oh this is a big
problem I just didn't see this idea oh I
should not have pushed be five I guess
okay how do I be tricky and somehow win
this I could risk losing this maybe try
and get f4 in
hmm
until I play B 5b 5a Moo 61 okay it's
gonna be very disappointing if I draw
this trying to calculate F for ticks
ticks I'm sacking he got five that might
actually work like that might work
let's just play out for ID used to take
eventually I'll try and calculate
thoroughly I don't think I'm in any rush
but okay if it works it works let's just
move around for a little bit
gain some time
so King g7 takes takes King there
with tricky
it's very tricky
six there
takes takes king of five fish left to
and g6 works I think take six king of
five right takes cakes king of 5 qg 7 g6
kept going for it's better not lose this
and this is a serious threat
oh my gosh and I losing this I might be
losing this no I I don't think I can
lose this I can bail out if I need to
okay this should be good I was more
scared of Bishop III they're so they're
so here it takes there and King g5 looks
good
I mean this might still be a draw
actually I have to try this I have to
play b6 what else to do
I'm not sure if it's winning or drawing
I'm not gonna lose this now I don't
think
ah that's a good move oh no am I gonna
lose us I might be losing this no oh no
I'm losing this oh I over push I over
pushed oh it's so sad that's so so sad
but am i losing this black stinking
black is thinking think for seven more
seconds
spraying art Kay thanks for this is
really bad
no losing this how am i losing this I do
bad things happen to good people
good game well played I should have
taken the draw when you offered it over
a post over foot I mean it's I assume
it's a draw
okay we'll play in just a moment to
Rebecca Harris ah it's not a good way
yeah it's just a draw so when did it
become losing key six b6o Kingi for it's
slow draw because I I'm in time to catch
this pawn okay time to play Rebecca
Harris I'll probably put that on youtube
people on YouTube give me an F in the
comments and be sure to LIKE the video
and subscribe